i
thought this was hilarious so this is um
a hearing and a chord hearing what
you're doing through zoom and stuff
here's what happened
mr ponton i believe you have a filter
turned on in the video settings
uh you might want to uh uh
we're trying to can you hear me judge
i can hear you i think it's a filter
it is and i don't know how to remove it
i've got my assistant here she's trying
to
but uh i'm prepared to go forward with
it
that's i'm here live that's not i'm not
a cat i can
i can see that um i think if you click
the
up
i'm prepared to go live here i'm not a
cat
it's not fake this is actually from uh
the 394th
judicial district court
okay we're watching that again from the
beginning it's a short video but it's
worth watching
mr ponton i believe you have a filter
turned on
in the video settings
uh you might want to uh uh
we're trying to can you hear me judge
i can hear you i think it's a filter
it is and i don't know how to remove it
i've got my assistant here she's trying
to but
uh i'm prepared to go forward with it
that's i'm here live that's not i'm not
a cat
i i can i can see that um
so uh we're gonna continue here with the
double murder case that we're
prosecuting
[Laughter]
it's too good it's just too good
cat lawyer
i'm assuming it's a lawyer but can you
imagine a [ __ ] this is your lawyer
is the guy who can't take the filters
cat filter off
yeah why is the cat so nervous
shut up he better be careful he may be
charged
with perjury don't start this please
don't don't [ __ ] start okay
stop dj coffin's knees it was the
perfect crime
[Laughter]
oh no
[ __ ]
jesus christ quit kitten around
right meow this is serious stop these
are stupid dad jokes and i want you to
stop
it was a histaminer okay come on
he was thinking this might get me out of
trouble
guys enough it's claw in order stop you
know we're done with this okay
these jokes are stupid and they're
childish
and i'm not putting up with them
pneumatic says settle down i will charge
you with contempt of court
stop it a felony no stop
we're done he was a cat burglar
we're done guys i just wanted to show
you a stupid video now for you to make
these stupid cat jokes okay enough
we're done schrodinger's judgment
okay i mean
i declare a his trial
enough enough
enough